bene i ragazzi e benvenuti sì ma questo
nuovo
siamo su youtube air simulator meno male
perché io non lo so fare vini magari
imparo fire progetti nella voce
interessante tutti parlo di queste
indiscrezioni mantendosi è la nintendo
milanese comunque
sì sì centro sicuramente bis che posso
andarci so se ho un miliardo di iscritti
porca [ __ ] quindi non ci posso andare
pur non posso infiltrarvi dentro il
games week c'è proprio dal tetto
cioè non lo so non so come fare entrare
la posso fare un video con il play con
questa è una tizia non c'entra un gala
faccio lo faccio le interviste
vabbè bella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questa nuova intervista ciao
zia non so chi cazzo sei tiwari ha steso
il mio canale bene gli adulti da solo
comunque io faccio un sacco di dio
divertenti e il cazzo sei risponderete
allibito precedente mentre forse
un'informazione utile
forse di formazione utile non dovresti
dire per a tutti i ragazzi fa schifo
effettivamente fa schifo quindi diciamo
sono out sono critiche che sono
costruttive 15 st
la zia è stata molto partecipe questa
intervista sono contento brava bene
ariel ci fa vedere se riesco registra un
altro video
c'è una roba qua che mi interessava
praticamente sicuro scoperto che esiste
un modo per avere il monopattino che
potrebbe essere interessante gianni alta
moda se ci sia comprarmi un mono piccolo
qua va in scooter ti serve un patentino
poi contenerlo questo il municipio va
bene al municipio che non so neanche
dove però che proviamo in piazza
municipio qua salve sabato e domeniche
più oggi che giorno e saba domenica
porca put a velo tornato ma i top domani
torno al municipio vediamo se c'è
qualcosa da riprendere non so cosa che
salta tendenze attuali quartieri alti ma
nessuno solo incula un chissenefrega se
torniamo a casa a montare video che
tanto sto giampiero non fa niente ma mi
segue basta facciamo un video di works
che se poi li montiamo ragazzi di carico
tutti insieme gameplay ma posso fare
anche nuova tipo le speedrun mi chiama
tutto bene
bellissimo allora salva e vediamo se
riesco a montare sti due video prima di
morire e di capito anche da strani come
ti fa montare cioè per montare video poi
montali anche la stanco zero energia non
gliene frega niente eccolo con ha detto
dai i file montare giampiero volta tu
per una volta montato dai salve a lunedì
8 posso andare al municipio ma primato
montare video platform sfida biglietto
gratis play e comunque non ha fatto
pubblica un cazzo cioè
le tendenze 5 ovviamente si scarica il
tipo è un nuovo gioco di successo
cyberwar
sarebbe cyberpunk va bene le dita video
posso mettere quello della mantendo no
perché nessuno si caga più la conferenza
mantenne indiscrezioni non si dica capi
nessuno devi essere devo essere più
veloce con le tendenze veloci perché non
funziona così se no 48 like let's go
come si può la guida pubblicato molto
anche se lo abbiamo fatto giampiero sa
benissimo allora anzi tutta diamo al
municipio perché se non non entro più mi
serve a prendere il patentino dello
scudo e spero non costi soldi che mi
serve colpo che andare già conosciuta mi
chiama e velocissimo salve esegui una
pratica
prende la patente per lo scooter una
licenza edilizia
duplicato le chiavi casi inoltre la
domanda di divorzio
ma cosa no
minchia non la prenderò mai a parte che
non i soldi comunque anche se li avessi
non passare l'esame quindi niente da
fare peccato gianni grazie del parco e
adesso vado a consegnarlo alla zia vado
a comprare cyberwar che un gran gioco
ragazzi poi faccio il dito su cyberwar
però che c'è un piano che voglia di
lavorare oggi cosa che non è detto e
giannone detto gente fidata mi ha detto
che in città sono youtuber superstar un
vero proprio lo trovi al centro città ma
solo per pochi giorni
se lo comincia a garantire perché sono
felicitati la copia del gioco va bene
andiamo allo youtuber super pro in
centro città alla ricerca del famoso
youtuber va bene un suggerimento sechi
crediamo che sia donare youtube perché
stiamo cercando il dio dalla barba
sportage è più viva il the center of the
city va bene
davvero youtuber biondo con la barba
voglia se riconosco pd va in giro
sto male e geniale ma dov'è il centro
città scusate io non l'ho capito la
mappa
il centro città dovrebbe essere tipo
quel municipio vediamo solo spot non è
lui è lui o non è lui lui da lui lui è
ricco anche qui poi sicuramente però il
cazzo è pd vice potrebbe essere ovunque
raga ma che se va beh certo
hannibal lecter dei cachi è sta roba
cos'è questa gente che gira così ma che
lui dottor dj fox youtuber ciao sei un
dj no mi chiamano così viene ragazzi
disco sulla scatola di musica va bene
raga non ho la più pallida idea di dove
possa essere più di pai non ne ho idea
in centro città ma non non lo vedo
oh my business è proprio lui
cambierei
fatto che ci sono passato davanti con
nonchalance eccolo è più di fi e la sua
cagnolina mai a chi meglio di lui potrà
garantire per il tuo lavoro
devo andare da più di paia farmi
raccomandarono tu che sei uno che fa
questo lavoro quando gli capita
dovrei fare un video su ore di
stamattina oggi questa mente sospetto
stava offrendo l'accesso a cyberwar la
gente ha perso la testa per questo gioco
ma sembra terribile perché si ferma la
gente davanti quattro era il profeta il
cazzo vuoi tu la offerto anche a te simo
ha bisogno di supporto di uno youtube di
qualcuno che vi faccia da garante
ho un'idea prendi questa mia fotografata
questi stizia capirà che ci conosciamo e
che lascerà accedere al gioco
va bene il dottore mi farà sapere quando
ce l'hai poi andiamo a casato
felix stessa cosa dire non s'era mai a
vi porterà a casa tua a 1 il fatto
incredibile che ne pensi sì sì nobel per
carità cioè speriamo che la trovi anche
se no poi c'è io marchio registriamo da
me
ottimo vai a prendere gioco ti aspetto a
casa tua ma scusami la domanda
stupidissima quale adesso mi tira un po
più incredibile si trovino presto
youtuber pezzente crede che io fare un
video con lui si sa che ingenuo e se va
comunque non mi fa mi fa strano perché a
quel punto potrei dire pure tu a
prendere il gioco a quel punto di venire
a casa mia a quel punto premier c'è ma
non capire a quel punto mi accompagnino
la siria lo zio c'è una fotografata di
baite è niente meno che più di pray
questa sì che è una garanzia
ti meriti di provare cosa vedo qua ecco
il tuo cyberwar grazie se già in casa
mia hai già fatto sneaking c'è sempre
entrati tipo così eccolo o malgara il
gioco sono presi di sapere cosa
scopriremo giocando dai registriamo il
video quanto ci fate da 1 milione che è
un pacco incredibile è in realtà adesso
sono qua colpi li fai per niente
fotografate di baila consulente da
cinquemila monete la cosa
colloca in casa
aspetta che la piazza fa guarda ferries
non voglio neanche la sveglia la mette
proprio quando la posso metta l'acqua
che mi guardi dormire far east qua a di
e dormo con tecnico hardy perfetto il
tuo viso dice che se il pieno di dubbi
spara come posso aiutarti il rivenditore
ci ha chiesto di spalmare sui nostri
contatti
lo sapevo vogliono provare un prodotto
scadente usando gli youtuber che si
lasciano corrompere con misere
bustarelle
benissimo e ci carica ma che gli è
venuto e mettere i bastard o la devi
entrare nel thread dei messaggi in modo
da segnalare usando il tuo talento che
per questa truffa prima di tutto
dobbiamo fare quello di vendita comunque
si trovi sai dove cercare da qua
mai e rintracciato diventi tale si trova
centro città vedrai prenderemo con il
truffatore ma prima devo andare a
cercare maglia ci vediamo direttamente
li scopri la truffa compiuti pasta
romani fa fare più virus del vivere cioè
dai tre ragazzi col culo quale episodio
per oggi poi continuiamo nel prossimo
diamo semmai a è riuscita a
io penso neanche più che di incredibile
comunque vedere like perché ho fatto
vito complicati schede hackerare era
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
è la ragazzi
[Musica]